retrouver manger
své avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires bonjour à tous Aujourd'hui
manger svoté dans une belle prairie
avyonnaise en surplom du village destin
qui se trouve juste là alors justement
c'est mon destin d'aller rencontrer le
sénateur les républicains Jean-Claude
anglar qui m'attend sur le pont qui
enjambe le lotte oui la rivière le lotte
on est en Ayon mais il y a quand même le
lotte je vais le
[Musique]
retrouver
je crois reconnaître le sénateur Anglars
apparemment contemplatif ce
matin monsieur le sénateur ah Monsieur
bonjour vous étiez absorbé dans la
contemplation de votre beau village
destin écoutez je ne m'en lasse pas
chaque fois que je reviens de Paris je
viens je m'assois ici puis je regarde le
villagein heureux de vous accueillir en
tout cas ici sur le bon des Stein qui
fait la limite entre la commune des
sains et la commune des sbrzac dont
j'étais mère ah bah voilà donc vous êtes
vraiment chez vous là une jambe de
chaque côté voil et alors
esttin ça sonne à l'oreille des Français
hein on connaît la famille destin en
tout cas on l'a bien connu alors alors
écoutez le village des saints est lié à
la famille des saints parce que
finalement les conttes des saints
prédécesseur de l'illustre président de
la République qui a qui a d'ailleurs
racheté le château en 2005 était une
vieille famille des saints d'ailleurs
vous voyez le pont sur lequel nous
sommes il y a une statue ici de François
des SA qui était donc évêque d'averon a
été celui qui a fait le clocher de la
cathédrale de rodè ah ça c'est un titre
de gloire voilà et alors je note qu'il y
a beaucoup de randonneurs qui passent
sur ce pont la particularité aussi desin
c'est que nous sommes sur le chemin de
Saint-Jacques de Compostelle dont le
pont comme une partie du chemin est
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO on peut se balader le long des
rives du Lot bien sûr avec plaisir bien
sûr Mons le sénateur alors si je
comprends bien là c'est plus chez vous
qu'en face voilà ici c'est ma commune
donc je suis je fus mère pendant 25 ans
ah ouais à 32 ans je fus mère et puis je
suis resté jusqu'en 2020 date des
sénatoriales au mois de septembre donc
j'ai dû démissionner bien sûr de ma
fonction de mère mais je suis resté
conseiller municipal et j'y tiens
beaucoup ah oui vous vous avez le
droitcage et puis c'est mon encrage
voilà et avant où avez-vu passer votre
enfance alors bon moi j'étais levé dans
une famille d'agriculteur sur la commune
de sbras une famille d'accueil ça
s'appelle voilà des gens qui avaient une
petite exploitation agricole pour les
cultures élevag donc j'ai grandi
vraiment dans le milieu agricole dans le
milieu paysan je suis d'ailleurs un
paysan dans l' lame le fait d'être
paysan ici du milieu ça donne du bon
sens h on appréhende des choses
différemment et donc des fois quand
j'assiste à des débats parfois
hubuesques sur des
sujets je me dis mais si les gens
avaient le sens un peu du bon sens
paysant de la terre de savoir ce que les
saisons Comment ça pousse les efforts
qu'il faut faire l'amour qu'on les gens
pour leur métier bon je me dis peut-être
les décisions à prendre seraient
beaucoup plus simples beaucoup plus
sages avant la politique politicienne on
est sous des choses qu'il faut faire
avancer avec l'idée de les faire avancer
voilà je pense que chaque fois qu'on
perd de la proximité euh les citoyens ne
savent plus ce que c'est moi je
maintiens je prétends que lorsqu'on est
un élu local les gens viennent dire
leurs problèmes et on les résout et on
leur donne aussi un espoir et donc
chaque fois qu'on éloigne de la
proximité le centre de décision je pense
qu'on se trompe euh on va entamer notre
périple par un viticulteur ah oui oui
oui on va on va chez la famille moussée
qui finalement de de génération en
génération plante des vignes développe
et puis sont vraiment accrochés allez on
y
va on va découvrir ensemble trava des
producteurs de BF fermier d'rac que nous
goûterons chez le boucher Lucien Conquet
un véritable chentre du bœuf fermier
d'rac et puis ensuite dans les caves de
Roquefort pour découvrir le secret de ce
fromage mythique et puis nous
terminerons au-dessus de la Yol sur le
plateau dans le restaurant de Sébastien
brass qui nous présentera des
spécialités de
[Musique]
l'avyon Jean-Claude on n pas quitté la
vallée du Lot qui coule en bas là et on
va rendre visite à des vignerons parce
que là on est entouré de vignes en
terrasse qui domine cette vallée du
lotte ici on est donc sur les
contreforts ici du Massif Central
commune du fel ils ont repris la culture
traditionnelle qu'il y avait ici h de
planter sur les côaux Sud exposé au
soleil la vigne donc ils ont refait ce
travail de façon très courageuse ce sont
des viticulteurs exemplaires bonjour
monesssieurs bonjour bonjour bonjour
enfin je dis messieurs mais excusez-moi
vous êtes des humains ou vous êtes des
chèvres
un peu les deux un peu les deux un peu
les deux montrez-moi si vous avez des
crampons sous les chaussures ils son ils
sont un peu Liss les MI il sont un peu
forceuse est-ce qu'on arrive sur des
terrains comme celui-ci à calculer en
surface plus il y a de pintes plus il y
a des talus qui sont haut et plus c'est
complique moins on a de pieds quoi h
mais on est entre 2 et 3000 3005 3500
pieds hectar quoi ouais d'accord mais
déjà c'est dans les terrains dans une
parcelle comme celle-ci on est à de le
pied cro quasimentou ou ouis non mais on
arrive à passer avec des petits
tracteurs et déjà mécanisé une partie
parce que ou et puis si c'est tout le
territoire ils ont su fédérer le
territoire pour convaincre les
propriétaires qu'il fallait planter et
puis que ça soit viable pour les jeunes
qui arrivent parce que les anciens même
si tu toi tu es jeune encore voilà avait
commencé à donner le tempo mais voilà
c'est de reprendre le sujet de faire que
les jeunes puissent s'installer voilà
parce qu'ici il mett en avant à la fois
le vin qu'ils font mais les paysages
mais sur ce vignoble il y a quatre
jeunes de moins de de 40 ans quoi il y a
une exploitation sur laquelle on a
réussi à installer une jeune fille et il
y a qu'une exploitation à l'heure
actuelle qui a pas de sucè session mais
bon il y a 2 hectares de viges on va
voir qu'est-ce que ça donne mais bon et
l'appellation c'est quoi alors ici c'est
entraille le fel
entraille le fel non de deux village
voilà et en plus vous êtes bio vous
voilà ouais en plus on est bio pour
autant vous avez des voisins qui sont
pas en bio non après c'est un choix
personnel conventionnel voilà ouais on
peut pas forcer tout le monde à passer
au bio ou tout le monde à être
conventionnel et je pense que c'est
complémentaire et c'est très bien comme
ça il faut que ça dure et qu'on qu'on
qu'on garde notre esprit paysan dans ide
dans tout ça moi je trouve que c'est
c'est formidable d'entendre parler mais
j'a bien qu'on goûte quand même oui il y
a pas de souci on vous
accompagne ça nous fera une pause allez
voilà allez ça grimpe don Laurent c'est
quoi ça c'est de la laine de mouton
laine de mouton pourquoi pour pas qu'er
non c'est pour empêcher l'herbe de
pousser autour des pieds dans les
engrais organiques bio maintenant on
voit il y a laine de mouton dedans il
réincorpore de la laine pour pour faire
des amendements c'est ça bientôt on aura
depuis l'over vert
alors j'aime bien ce petit bruit hein ah
oui c'est ah c'est
çaant là donc c'est notre CUV ha de
gamme en blanc 100 % chenin ça vient de
de l'occitan donc pay routi petite
pierre est-ce que ici sur une
appellation de 20 haares à travailler en
bio tout à la main est-ce qu'on arrive à
en vivre Pierrick on arrive à en vivre à
condition de voilà de faire attention à
ce qu'on fait financièrement et à ce
qu'on achète nous c'est vrai qu'on a la
chance de venir du monde paysan donc
voilà beaucoup de bricolage beaucoup de
6md et des investissements assez faibles
au départ aussi ce qui permet d'avoir
coup de revient qui est un peu plus bas
et en avyon c'est vraiment un sujet
fondamental la transmission
d'exploitation on est toujours en Ayon à
132 et 150 installations de jeunes
agriculteur viticulteur ou autre mais
toujours 300 départ vous quel âge
Laurent je vais avoir 58 ans ah bah vous
avez encore du temps alors je vous
annonce un truc il est pas encore à la
retraite hein mais j'ai commencé à 18
ans alors j'espère que que j'aurai le je
vais vous dire le jour où vous la
prendrez cette retraite je vous la
souhaite heureuse et à vous Pierric une
belle vide Vignon merci
merci ce sénateur on va quitter la
vallée du Lot direction l'obrac on va
prendre un peu d'altitude on va
rejoindre argent aurac et on va
retrouver je Valadier dans la cuisine
communale il va nous montrer ce qu'il
fait avec les produits locaux pour les
petits et pour les plus
[Musique]
anciens bonjour bonjour à l'équipe c'est
la chef qui est là-bas la chef céine
alors Céline vous êtes combien en
cuisine 4 ici on est 4 oui c'est l'heure
où vous êtes en train de faire quoi là
là on est en train de finir la soupe a
été mis pour la DMR le portage la
dmrleded à Domicile en Milieu Rural ah
oui parce queors là vous les acronymes
moi je suis pas très doué hein portage
de repas portage de repas c'est ça si je
comprends bien
jeanvadiier ici vous avez fait le choix
d'arrêter de concéder la restauration et
vous êtes passer à du locavore quoi pur
alors aujourd'hui nous avons une
politique collective qui nous engage à
travailler du du produit de grande
proximité nous sommes sur une terre
d'élevage la viande c'est pas difficile
lorsqu'il s'agit d'allû chercher de la
salade c'est plutôt la vallé de lot
alors on sert qui Lucile ici c'est un
public très large puisque le service de
restauration communale l'intérêt c'est
de faire manger nos tout petits ouais
tout petit quel âge du territoire alors
il commence à rentrer en crèche en
général autour de 10m voilà et ensuite
on fait manger aussi donc les enfants de
l'école et nos aînés qui bénéficient du
portage de 2 ans à 92
ansob 10 semaines à
99 l'équipe de restauration fait des
textures très différente et le projet
qu'elle porte est autour de ces textures
très différentes il s'agit pas de de
lisser les produits et de les rendre
informme mais ça aussi ça participe à
l'éveil au goût au maintien de la santé
on n parle pas assez mais le premier pas
de la santé c'est ce qu'on se met dans
l'assiette et combien ça coûte aux
familles alors alors le choix politique
est aussi d'accompagner les familles
puisque aux familles ça leur coûte selon
ctient familial entre 2,20 € et 3
€50 à peine à
peine
[Musique]
sont partis n'en parlons plus
bonjour je me disais la restauration
change les chansons restent les mêmes
hein oui j'ai fait un grand voyage en
arrière tout le boulot c'est de les
autonomiser le plus rapidement possible
à peu près 20 % qui va dans la bouche et
le reste sur la serviette c'est le jeu
c'est comme ça qu'on apprend personne
nous regarde
non
h
[Musique]
encore au
revoir ah ben oui ça c'est le muret
c'est le muret il y en a partout ici
sépare les les prê se sénateur on est en
obrac ici alors ici on est exactement à
Argence à obrac qui est sur le plateau
de l'obrac derrière nous il y a le lac
de Sarang il a le lac artificiel on est
audessus de la Truyère et alors vous
m'avez confié un bâton ici la
particularité du bâton qu'on vous a
donné c'est que ça s'appelle un drélier
un drélier un drélier qui est fait donc
avec un arbre d'ici qui s'appelle
l'alisier c'est très léger et très très
dur et la légende dit il y avait ce
qu'on appelait la justice de la yole qui
se réglait avec le drelllier
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour Voilà
bonjour Olivier là vous leur donnez des
friandises là qu'est-ce que c'est des
céréales des céréales produit sur
l'exploitation ah vous produisez vous
êtes en autonomie sur l'alimentation des
bêtes oui oui oui nous en faisons pas
beaucoup mais juste ce qu'il nous
faut du FO aussi pour l'hiver du FO pour
l'hiver ou donc l'été à la période
estival tu relherve et on récolte foin
pour faire les d'accord pour faire les
stocks pour le pour l'hiver ou ils sont
104 ici sur la commune sur ce plateau
104 organis etleveur comme comme toi he
comme vous c'est ça c'est extraordinaire
voilà et en tout sur l'ensemble des
départements de 9000 exploitations et
11000 chefs d'exploitation c'est-à-dire
que par exemple chez eux ils sont deux
en Gaek donc ça fait deux voilà c'est
une vache la rass au qui est dite mixte
elle donne du lait qui va faire le
fameux fromage de la gule et mais elle
donne aussi viande vous avez combien de
bêtes vous ah ben alors avec risel on
élève 140 vaches qui font leur vaau
chaque année voilà parce que j'ai vu un
beau taureau là dans le tropauoui
comment il s'appelle celui-là Nelson
Nelson oui oui il a trouvé de la
compagnie pour
aujourd'hui ceux qui ne connaissent pas
du tout l'élevage de race à viande ne
savent pas à quel point on apporte du
soin alors on les laissent évidemment
brouterin mais il y a toujours ce ce
dernier travail dernier travail voilà et
ça c'est le travail de l'éleveur qui est
les éleveurs extraordinaire parce qu'ici
on est finalement sur un système
extensif de haute qualité
environnementale c'est les mots qu'il
faut utiliser il faut le dire au
consommateur à tout parce que finalement
les vaches broutent de l'herbe et après
on sait quand on fait une la finition
comme ici les bœufs fermers au bras ce
qu'il faut à la fin pour que le
consommateur il apprécie que ça devienne
une viande de grande qualité ici la
chance qu'on a c'est que ce sont des
filières c'estàdire de l'éleveur
n'est-ce pas au boucher à celui qui
consomme il y a une filière organisée
hein ici on a la particularité et je dis
souvent d'avoir beaucoup d'ambassadeurs
à Paris qui sont partis de ce territoire
d'ver laavyon du Cantal la Lazer
n'est-ce pas à Paris qui sont nos
meilleurs ambassadeurs dans la
restauration bien dans la restauration
voilà et donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'important bon alors ce bœuf fermé
d'rac là la belle rouge je crois qu'il
est temps d'aller pour nous rendre
visite à Lucien il est c'est un des des
maillons de la filière indispensable
parce que là vous m'avez donné envie
merci Olivier merci Christelle à bientôt
au revoir Olivier au revoir ist on va
aller voir de la belle bidoche
allez bon monsieur le sénateur ici on
est à la guule bah c'est pour ça qu'on
va chez conquy hein qui porte le goût de
l'obrac dans le monde entier qui est un
ami nous étions à l'école ensemble avec
Lucien alors voilà bonjour Lucien de
passage dans notre village carrément
village d'rac on a eu le point de vue de
l'éleveur sur la race moi ce que je
voudrais c'est le point de vue du
boucher pour qu'elle soit bonne et
goûteuse il faut qu'elle soit je veux
dire déjà élevé tout doucement alors
sans cilage on a interdit l'enilage et
le maïs on rappelle ce que c'est que
l'encilage l'enilage c'est de l'herbe
fermentéer voit souvent sous des baches
noir
d'as c'est pas naturel voilà simplement
d' donc du foin séché et le reste dans
les prairies dans les prairies tout à
fait pendant l'estive d'accord ça c'est
un c'est c'est très important ils ont
pas écrit le cahier des charges ils ont
écrit le cahier des ressources ils on
utilisé les ressources locales pour
écrire voilà pour mettre enforme quelque
chose pour que le consommateur parce que
ce qui est important c'est le
consommateur et on a quand même plus de
500 adhérents ce C déchge 500 éleveurs
alors parce que si vous voulez quand je
parle des ateliers d'ingressement ils
vont vous engresser 1000 animaux par an
nous on n même pas capable de le manger
dans la voilà dites-moi Lucien il paraît
qu'elle est tellement exceptionnelle
cette viande qu'on peut la manger telle
qu'elle crue je peux la goûter oui ça
fait un peu des copos c'est pas
mal
[Musique]
top ouis parce que le grain est
super dans un BF il y a 33 morceaux
différents et chacun assimilé à sa forme
dit mer par la forme d'un poisson
une poire c'est la forme d'une poire
pourquoi on appelle ça une bavette parce
que voil çaette forme forme l'excellence
passe par les artisans on le disait tout
à l'heure ici à la l'excellence le
couteau il y av le fromage et il a la
viande
ce sénateur apprè notre escapa dans nos
bracs direction plein sud on va chez
Jérôme faramon producteur de lait de
brebille
[Musique]
pourfort bonjour Jérôme Jérôme le
berger ce sont des brebis lacô c'est ça
c'est ça de race laacne tout à fait de
race LAAC qui sont en fait les brebis de
l'appellation Rockfort il faut que ça
soit de la laconne c'est obligatoire
dans le cahier des charges c'est écrit
comme ça si c'est pas une laconne ça
fera pas du du lait pour le Rockfort
voilà et combien il y en a là dans cette
parcelle et ben là il y en a 640 ah non
je pense qu'il y en a 639 j'en ai vu une
toute seule là-bas ah oui ah une rebelle
elle elle a sauté la barrière mais les
moutons on sait que ça saute les
barrière petit passage ah ça c'est rare
quand même non ça va on arrive à les
contenirme 2022 sortie du covid on a
évidemment cette inflation galopante et
10 % de mon moins de vente de Rockfort
ça sent au niveau des éleveurs ah oui ça
sent ça sent beaucoup alors déjà là pour
le coup les fabricants ont augmenté le
prix donc déjà il y a une compensation
par le prix heureusement mais après ben
ça fait d'autres volumes le lait n'est
pas jeté on compense par une
valorisation autre c'est de la récession
plus que de l'augmentation monsieur le
sénateur avant 2015 il y avait une
régulation des prix d'achat du lait et
puis comme d'habitude dès qu'il s'agit
de fromage et de particularisme français
l'Europe met son est dedans sous les
dictate de l'Europe du Nord et de
l'Allemagne et paf on a une dérégulation
totale qui fait comme le disait Jérôme
que les prix du lait sont laissés à
l'appréciation de ceux qui achètent et
qui négocient avec ceux qui vendent moi
j'ai connu le système d'avant 2015 de
l'interprofession il négocier ensemble
le prix et il faut revenir un peu de bon
sens on a longtemps parlé ici du bon
sens et je trouve qu'ici entre les
industriel comme les Appell ici les
fabricants et les producteurs il y avait
une façon de fonctionner qui était
intéressante puisque le prix du lait
était fonction des ventes donc c'était
vraiment le consommateur qui fixait les
choses et c'était quelque chose
d'intéressant là pour le coup manger
c'était voté quand on achetit du manger
c'était voté voilà bon on est bien là
l'herbe est haute les premis sont belles
et heureuses mais pour ce qui me
concerne il y a que de l'herbe à manger
ça me va pas on parle de Rockfort depuis
quelques minutes j'ai envie de goûter du
Rockfort je vais vous laisser on va
aller à Rockfort
[Musique]
làine vous êtes là je suis par là venez
descendez ah Madame Carle bonjour
bonjour bonjour Madame Carle ça sent
très bon ici hein alors qu'est-ce que
vous étiez en train de faire quand on
arrivé là là je suis en train de de
sonder pour voir l'évolution du bleu
parce qu'on met les fromages sur travé
de bois pour l'affinage et le bleu va se
développer petit petit pour faire du
Rockfort qu'est-ce qu'il faut du du lait
de Breb du lait de brebis de race
laaconne oui donc ça c'est commun à tout
le monde c'est c'est dans dans laop il
faut qu'il a du pénicilum
roqueforti il faut que le fromage soit
piqué avant de de venir en cave et il
faut qu'il soit en cave naturelle à
Roquefort dans le sous-sol et obligation
de laisser le fromage affiner minimum 15
jours donc ça c'est le le Tron commun ce
sont ces caves naturelles et ces failles
qu'on appelle des fleurine à travers
lesqueles passent des courants d'air
tout à fait et qui amène frais et humide
voit et on a n'importe quelle saison la
même température et la même taux
d'humidité vous vous avez conservé le
bois vous avez conservé le chîne nous on
a conservé le pourquoi parce que ça
garde des ferments particuliers c'est
naturel et ça ça protège en quelque
sorte aussi leage au niveau
bactériologique c'est c'est top on met
pas de produits chimiques
désinfectant et c'est sain alors ça
tombe bien qu'on qu'on soit dans une
cave parce que général en France quand
on dit la grande muette on parle de
l'armée il y a une deuxième grande
muette c'est la profession du Rockfort
hein parce qu'on a l'impression quand
même ici que le silence est loi parce
que il y a des choses qu'on aime pas
trop remuer on naime pas trop remuer la
boue du de l'artisanat face au monde
industriel en matière de laitterie mais
ici il y a pas de Bou il y a se
fabricants de Rockfort qui faont un
produit internationalement connu qui
doivent respecter parfaitement le cahier
des charges et ça c'est très important
pour le territoire parce que derrière il
y a des éleveurs et derrière les
éleveurs il y a des fromagers des
fabricants comme ici madame car a fait
le choix de perpétuer la tradition comme
le faisait sa famille avant elle
d'autres ont fait d'autres choix mais
vous vous êtes un peu vous êtes un peu
quand même des des appaches ici hein
c'està dire les les irréductibles
Gaulois les irréductibles oui oui le
dernier Moor non mais on a l'impression
quand même que c'est un un village qui
appartient à ce grand groupe laitier
combien vous en produisez vous Delphine
on produit
1,54 % très
exactement
l' ça représente combien de rockfor dans
l'année
représente à peu près 78000
fromages donc il en sort des rockfor de
rockfor et la zone d'appellation Ava été
réduite oui la zone de collecte
duil c'est l'Avon et un peu de l'éro ce
qui me ferait plaisir Delphine c'est de
sonder un de vos Rockfort et ben allez
génial quel
honneur 1 2
[Musique]
3 je préfères sentir auocéateur sentir
mais pas goûter pas goûter ah non on
peut pas goûter ah on pe pas goûter à
cette étape ah ben voilà il est pas
encore pr voilà c'est parce qu'il n pas
vous goûtez avec les yeux je goûte avec
les
yeux ça ge tout le temps ça ge tout le
temps ici c'est une des caractéristiques
du département ça monte et ça descend
nous sommes à éidistance entre laayole
et au braque au suquette au suquette
donc la maison brasse su dans la maison
brasse comment ça va comment allez-vous
bien formidableven on est monté à pied
de laolle vrai ou enfin bon triche un
petit peu avec le sénateur on aurait pu
plus bon
Jean-Claude cuisinier débutant on est
d'accord cuisinier débutant voilàon
c'est très bien est-ce que je pense que
monsieur le sénateur ne se rend pas
compte que par exemple pour avoir un
atelier cuisine avec Sébastien brass les
japonais c'est 3 ans d'attente à peu
près mais quand on est de l'obrac on a
on a des petits pass droit alors voilà
moi je veux bien ah bah alors on va
peut-être lui montrer que ce poids mange
tout on parfois un petit fil qui vient
courir tout le long donc on fait juste
une petite entaille tu vois sur le
premier tiers et ensuite tu vas basculer
le couteau et tirer sans couper tu vois
regarde tu as vu et voilà gr le F ça
l'air très facile mais je vais bien
essayer il a pas il y en a pas pas
continue
d'accord il y en a pas qu'est-ce qu'il
sont beau c'est mange tout incroyable en
fait j'ai déjà enlevé tous les fils
[Musique]
avant je trouve que je suis doué
hein Jean-Claude anglar quand même à
quoi ça tient cette impression qui a une
qualité de vie en aviron alors ici on a
un mot pour qualifier le bon sens on
appelle ça le bis avec les moyens qu'on
a on veut bien faire est-ce que c'est ce
bon sens que vous voulez apporter aux
lois françaises et à l'état écoutez
chaque jour à chaque texte que nous
avons c'est ce que j'essaie de faire et
ce que j'ai trouvé d'extraordinaire
peut-être au Sénat c'est que quels que
soient les appartenances politiques on
trouve surtout les bancs sur des sujets
comme ça qui vont all l'essentiel des
gens de tous les bancs qui veulent
partager ceci et finalement c'est
peut-être la la richesse du Sénat et des
sénatrices et des sénateurs qui viennent
des territoires qui encore les pieds
dans les territoires et auquel on rêve
partager des choses et donc moi chaque
fois que je le peux j'essaie d'amener
oui ce B à la loi au texte qu'on examine
ah voilà le chef on va passer aux choses
sérieuses quand il commenca à faire un
peu FA comme on dit hein les petits riz
d'agneau qui sont poil légèrement glacé
on na pas envie de goûter hein pasvie ah
bah oui c'est tellement beau ouais ça
fait de la peine he c'est dé
touché je goûte moi merveilleux
[Musique]
ouais c'est très bon vraiment et
l'oignon est mais tu vois c'est le le
goût de
l'avyon le goût de l'avyon on en rêve et
Jean-Claude anglar nous l'a fait
découvrir aujourd'hui merci et nous on
vous fait découvrir les régions de
France dans manger s vter évidemment sur
public C et vous pourrez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur la nouvelle
plateforme publicsena.fr à très
[Musique]
vite c'était manger ses vter avec
Mutualia la mutuelle des territoires
[Musique]